tonight a family's search for answers
has finally ended nearly three years
after school bus driver billy burts was
killed in a hit-and-run crash the person
responsible has been brought to justice
sasha loftis spoke with those who knew
and loved billy she joins us live in our
newsroom with a bit more on their
message
brian billy's family says their prayers
have been answered nearly three years
after this tragic crash they say they
never gave up hope and now they can
breathe again
he was just
a fun loving person nearly three years
ago billy burt's life was suddenly
stolen and every single day since his
family has searched for answers it's
hard especially when
people can just walk away from something
like that the 52-year-old was hit and
killed by a car while on his motorcycle
near craig and lamb in december of 2018.
the other driver left the scene but just
last month a long awaited update came as
police took julia solis calderon into
custody in connection with the case for
her not to stop
to see which at least he was okay and
what and what you hit
and that's not even
i can't even forgive her her arrest
won't bring billy back but his sister
and stepfather can breathe a sigh of
relief my prayers were answered
when they found out that she was
arrested after so much suffering they
finally have closure
as they continue to remember the man
they loved
and still miss more than anything just
don't give up eventually
you will get your justice
that calderon faces charges for not
stopping at the site of a crash
involving injury or death she did post
bail last month and is due back in court
on december 9. reporting live in the
newsroom tonight sasha loftis 8 news now